no running water david or electricity
living with an outhouse okay that's poor
if you want to have impact uh usually
delegation is important
this is something that i would i think
uh
it's super important for young people to
understand wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
seven
best lessons from billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one don't be ashamed of your past
with oprah winfrey
you came from very modest circumstances
you didn't come from a wealthy family
well modest is not the word
well i was trying to be polite i was i
was actually
poor and i you know a lot of the girls
at my school actually all the girls from
my school
are poor and i was saying to them just
recently i was just in south africa for
graduation
you know you all are comf come from the
same circumstances you were poor
and one of the girls raised their hand
said i don't like using that word
i go well if you're not poor then you
should excuse yourself because
that's why i'm paying for you because
you're in my school so if you're not but
you don't like the choice of the word
so i don't i don't have a problem with
the word i don't have any shame about it
i think
you know probably earlier in my life or
career
the word would have bothered me but it
truly it was it was i was poor
no running water david or electricity
living with an outhouse okay that's poor
lesson number two overcome doubt with
elon musk
or maybe i just blank out the word doubt
um
so uh no i mean i totally frank i
doubted us too
so i i thought we you know had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who who doubted us
i was like well i think you're probably
right
you know i mean there were times
that i was told like uh because i was
taking the
money that i earned from from paypal and
enrolling into
to create spacex and tesla and and as
they ended up spending it all
it wasn't the intention but um
and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon one
um and uh so
but a lot of times i was you know i
people would tell me this joke like
how do you make a small fortune in the
rock industry you start with a large one
is the
punch line and i was like okay i already
heard that joke
12 000 times you know so
so anyway um and it was it almost came
true
um you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch
of falcon one that's all the money we
had for that fourth launch
and then uh and that wasn't even enough
to save the company we also then had to
win the nasa cargo resupply contract
um so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later
all right towards the end of 2008. um
those are the two
key things that that saved spacex
otherwise we would have we would have
you know not made it so
um so yeah i think those those doubters
were
their probability assessment was correct
um but fortunately
uh vader smiled upon us and brought us
to this day
lesson number three seek compatible
partners with warren buffett
we go back to when i started my
partnership in 1956
that berkshire came out of there were
seven people sitting there at a table
having dinner relatives primarily and i
said here's the partnership agreement
it's done under nebraska law it's four
or five pages you don't need to read it
but i said here's a little half page
what i call the ground rules and i want
you to read these
and if you feel okay about that about
the interaction what the expectations
are and all of that sort of thing
then we'll join forces and if you don't
it's fine
other people have you know but we don't
we shouldn't be partners i mean
you know if i'm gonna have a partnership
with somebody i want to be compatible it
is
you know and when you have a
public company you can't control who
comes in i can't control some guy that
comes in and thinks we're gonna pay big
dividends or split the stock or
something like that
so by my actions and my communications
and everything
i want to attract the people that
from the public market that i want and i
want to keep the others away
costco was built sal price who started
the price club
that thing he sat down and figured out
the customer he didn't want
and he set up a system that would keep
away the customer he didn't want who did
not want he didn't want somebody buying
a quart of milk with somebody behind
them with a
with a basket of 200 worth of goods
waiting for that
so we put in a membership fee and by
putting in a membership page
he killed all the drop in business the
business to belong to the 7-eleven
we want berkshire to to keep out people
who have expectations about us that are
different than ours
i mean good for them and i hope they
find somebody they said
but if you're going to run a church you
you want
you want your seats to be filled by
people that are generally want to
listen to your form of religion and you
don't want it to change every week and
say gee i need a new group and i'll go
out and talk to a bunch of investors and
get them to come to my church this
sunday because there's only so many
seats in the church
there's a million 645 000 or so
a equivalent shares and those are the
seats and i want them occupied by people
that are on the same page i am
also if you want to have unstoppable
confident self-love and learn from
billionaires check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join are in the description
below there are just times when
something is important enough that you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear they made
us do all these crazy things to get out
of ourselves and so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things align
yourself with the dream
because the dream could cannot come to
you unless you're willing to meet
it energetically in the same place
lesson number four learn to delegate
with bill gates
if you want to have impact uh usually
delegation's
important although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started i wrote most the code
and everybody else's code i read and
kind of rewrote
and that got us up to 10 people
and then i had to say to myself okay
we're going to ship code that i didn't
edit
uh and that was hard for me but
you know i kind of got over that then i
still said okay i'm going to interview
everyone and i'm going to at least look
at samples of their code well that got
us up to about 40 people
and that was at a point where i had sold
way more software than we could write
because everybody was so
impressed and i thought well i need
to keep enough collect enough money to
you know keep hiring all these people
but uh
the demand was so high that you know we
were actually falling behind that's when
i hired steve
and steve figured out a uh
how to control what promises i made to
people uh
and b how to hire lots of people and
good really good people and create
organizations and teams so i delegated
to steve that
and he was constantly saying to me okay
we're gonna hire programmers that you've
never met and i'd say no or not
and then he would show me numerically
that
the constraint wasn't gonna work uh you
know so
uh then i said okay then i would you
know
know all the managers of the people and
so over time
uh and of course you know i could say
the quality per
person was falling monotonically uh
uh according to me uh
but you know large problems uh
if you wanna you know write the most
popular office productivity software
that one person absolutely can't do that
you can write pretty code so
everyone has to decide what scale of
organization they want to
work in eventually you know my role was
very much as a leader
and a reviewer of managers but the top
people and i hired some super
experienced people
uh i would make sure they were pursuing
a common vision and they were well
coordinated
but in terms of a lot of management
stuff
they were way better than i was now i
had to have the framework
to know what mix of skills that we
needed and
you know when they were working well
enough together but a lot of
uh you know my value-added was picking
say to do graphics user interface or to
do an integrated office
uh type thing or to go global and not
use agents to have microsoft be present
all over the world
and so yeah picking what you're good at
and how you find the other people
to fill in those things that's super
important and most founders don't
aren't able to scale that up and kind of
give up the hands-on things that they
used to get a lot of
uh pleasure and comfort from lesson
number five
make great choices with jeff bezos
take pride your choices aren't your
gifts this is something that
um i would i think is super important
for young people to understand and for
parents to preach to young people it's
really easy for a talented young person
to take pride in their gifts they can
say you know i'm really athletic or i'm
really smart or i'm really good at math
and that's fine you should celebrate
your gifts you should be happy
but you can't be proud of them because
they're gifts after all
they were given to you what you can be
proud of is your choices
how did you decide to use your gifts did
you
study hard did you work hard did you
practice
the people who really excel combine gift
gifts and hard work and the hard work
part is a choice
you get to decide that and that is
something
when you're looking back on your life
you'll be very proud of lesson number
six
go step by step with jack ma i came here
to share with you the
entrepreneur's spirit in the dreams
this is what i learned from the other
part of the world i learned from the
american dreams
i learned from many other startups in
the whole world
that the stream of how they do it i
think the very important
is that making sure your dream can be
realized
making sure your dream makes steps by
step
every week every month and making sure
that
your employees believe in making sure
your customers are happy
because your if your customer happy your
employees are happy
the shareholder will be happy do not try
to spend a lot of time with your
shareholders
spend enough time with your customers
spend enough time with your employees
and even do not spend a lot of time with
the competitors because
you are we are all so early stage
the best way to compete to to fight
against your competitor
is your customers it's your colleagues
and lesson number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is understand technology with mark cuban
there's nothing that ai won't impact as
big as the
so bit having been around a while i saw
the impact of pcs then i saw the impact
of low query networks
then i saw the impact of wide area
networks then i saw the impact of the
internet
then i saw the impact of mobile then i
saw the impact of wireless
you know now i'm seeing the impact of of
artificial intelligence
and it dwarfs any of those things and if
i don't understand how to apply it to my
businesses
i mean i remember selling pcs and
software and walking in saying
you don't need to use that pen and paper
on on a you know on a notepad or
a ledger pad now we're going to give you
a spreadsheet and
by the way here's a here's a spreadsheet
that costs 495 dollars and
i had to pay to go get trained on how to
sell it which is crazy now when you
think about it
but then we said okay now you can play
what if then we said you can connect
these pcs
unless i understood the technology how
was i going to explain it
how was i going to understand it unless
i understand it now how am i going to
invest in it
you know then i got to go trust somebody
who says oh yeah i know ai
and maybe they do maybe they don't and
it's really easy
just to have just to okay so you figure
it out that's just not my style
so you're building a base of knowledge
and then you think that at some point
it's going to pay dividends and trust
already has right i mean if you truly
believe ai is going to change everything
how are you going to understand what
people are doing to change everything
unless you at least have a foundational
understanding of it now i'm not going to
build
a million layer neural network and try
to change the world and i'm not going to
show you i'm not going to write a
research paper and saying here's how
why the lottery ticket approach works
and you can build smaller neural
networks
with less data and be more you know
resource efficient but i can read that
stuff and understand that when somebody
says okay we're building this project
and we need this size data set or this
size data set we need this amount of
resources i can ask questions and
understand the answers
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below write down your single biggest
takeaway as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
i would call myself a girl who really
likes to challenge yourself to do things
that scare her to auditioning at disney
world
i ended up at disney world because i
failed the lsat and
i felt very sad that i
most likely wasn't going to be heading
off to law school i am a terrible test
taker
so i did what my parents said of course
would be the most natural thing to do
and i got in my car and drove to disney
world and tried out to be goofy
and just to add you know
insult to injury i'm too short to be
goofy
so i just failed the lsat i went through
all the auditions to become a character
and you have to be five eight to be
goofy and i'm five six so i'm the height
of a chipmunk
oh really yes so they wanted to make me
a chipmunk
[Music]
if you want to change your life in 30
days for free check the link right below
me and if you want seven more
lessons from billionaires check out the
video right there continue to believe
and i'll see you there